according to Bryce Dallas Howard the
kiss between her character Claire and
Chris Pratt's Owen was never in the
script for Jurassic world she told Out
magazine we had shot the scene in the
way that it was written there was no
kiss and then on the last day that
happened what you see in the movie the
movie's director Colin travaro however
has since revealed that it wasn't
entirely spontaneous he took Pratt aside
and suggested he kissed Howard but never
told her on Jurassic world's commentary
he explained the idea was we're just
going to have Chris Pratt's surprise
Howard in front of 200 people and that's
the take that's in the movie to see the
full video and more great content check
out our Channel And subscribe